hey dan what's up so there is some merit
to
uh the benefits of urine um tried
everything i could to
fix some janky nails on my foot
peed on it every day for a week in the
shower the nails turned around
athlete's foot gone fungus gone
and i still do it to this day remember
when you had your foot
fungus that uh i still have it on both
big toes
and you know what i'm seriously thinking
and what's the big deal
try on my toes that'd be great
if it works i want to know it would be
crazy if gary peed on his foot and after
like 30 years it finally made that
fungus go away
i've tried everything so i'm serious
i'll report back if it works it'd be
insane
so what are you going to do you're going
to get in the shower what is it on your
big toes
both big toes i'll just put them
together and i'll just piss on them
you should just like piss in a cup and
soak your toe like for a while like
i'm looking at the people's pharmacy
and it says it may take months of foot
soaks
to get rid of the nail fungus you just
can't pee on your feet and then
take a shower i'll give it two weeks
i'll give it two weeks i'm really gonna
try it
i gotta admit when gary came over and i
saw those things
i was like man i really don't want him
in my pool i've done everything you can
imagine there was medicine that i took
for a while that didn't work and then um
they put the stuff that you apply on it
doesn't work and then the last thing i
was doing was
my my podiatrist was going around with
this it's basically
like electrical shocking they like they
use electricity
to go through all the tools it hurts
like a [ __ ] that didn't work
uh bobby you're on the air in new jersey
well what i would like to see is if
gary's really going to try this
to only do it on one toe this way it
gives us a little bit of validity
on whether or not it really works or if
it's just a placebo effect
here's the deal i'm going to take a
picture of my toes today
and i'm going to do this for two weeks
and then after two weeks we'll see what
we got
okay take off your shoes show rob in
your feet
let's see the towel now bend your foot
look at that thing oh
thank you look at that oh no
look at that toenail oh
it's like fighting it off your body
right now